[Music]
it's Friday
finally tonight notable quotables
hopefully we'll have a meeting in the
12th doesn't happen June 12th it could
happen there after the summit is on
track maybe not for June 12 and it's
probably likely to be delayed the
process will begin on June 12th in
Singapore you'll see plenty of a woman
of Steel around it just be made by
American hands not really that great
vacation that I was looking for but
we're still together I would like to
apologize to my wife for the hell she
has had to go through the past two days
there is nothing that could be more
terrifying for a kid to go to school and
not feel safe they gave up two lives for
their country the one they were living
and the one they would have lived I'm
fine I cannot allow those forces to
continue to cause pain and difficulty to
the people that I love
every time it rains hard you say Hail
Mary and hope it's not the time here we
are
it was time it's just nothing to fool
with there are lots of really good
lawyers in the country you could have
picked someone else say say impeachment
sweetheart just say it
I had that face if I had that head of
hair I would have been president so long
ago the president really I never quite
saw this do I have social skills I don't
know that's social media this for sure
we've talked about almost everything
we've talked about a lot one week